foreign
welcome back to another video session by
simply learn in this session on C plus
plus full course for beginners we will
be learning different concepts and
topics of C plus plus
this video tutorial will help in
learning and understanding the C plus
programming language in both theoretical
and practical way by doing some Hands-On
examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update
so we'll start with the introduction to
C plus programming language and how to
download and install C plus plus in
Windows then we will start with the
first programming C plus plus along with
the terms like variables types then the
concepts like if else statements Loops
functions in C plus plus call by value
call by reference and friend function
then we will cover topics like arrays
pointers in C plus plus this pointer
references and memory management we will
also learn about sorting in C plus plus
after that we will move on to object
oriented programming topics like classes
in C plus plus oops Concepts Etc and
after that we will move on to topics
like vectors in C plus plus STL that is
standard template library and in the end
we'll also learn to make some projects
in C plus
so without further Ado let's get started
so let's start with the introduction to
C plus plus programming
C plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by John strowstrup
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called C with classes
as it was an extension to C language but
later renamed as C plus plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
C plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
Etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well
and in today's video we will be
discussing top 10 reasons to learn C
plus plus in 2022
C plus plus is an object oriented
language which is used in many Superior
organizations to create some complex
applications
and C plus plus is quite all language so
there are some doubts regarding the C
plus plus language like whether this
language is still in demand or not
and if it is then what are the reasons
to learn C plus plus programming
language
C plus plus is no doubt bit old language
but it is still in the dominance in the
world of programming in many sectors
in this video we will be discussing the
top 10 reasons to learn C plus plus
programming in 2022
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn
so we will start with the 10th reason
which is career opportunities
with the availability of easy to learn
languages like JavaScript python Etc
people often ignore languages like C
plus plus
C plus plus is considered a foundation
language of many programming languages
and is one of the most essential
languages that you must know if you are
interested in computer science
as per the tiobe index of 2022 C plus
plus lies in the fourth position in
terms of world's most popular language
the career or job opportunities for C
plus plus programmers is enormous
because C plus plus is an old language
and a lot of code is already written in
this language
C plus plus is very useful for making
complex softwares Android applications
and Games Etc
so it holds a strong position when it
comes to job opportunities
now let's move on to the next reason to
learn C plus plus programming language
which is
C plus plus is efficient and fast
language
C plus plus is a fast language its
compile time and execution time is
faster than other programming languages
some programming languages are also
faster than Z Plus but like C plus plus
they are not close to the machine code
as it is an intermediary language so big
organizations rely or depend on C plus
plus for fast speed with lesser
resources
so our eighth reason to learn C plus
plus language is
suitable for big projects yes C plus
plus is well suited for big projects
many applications and softwares that we
use or go through in our daily lives are
developed in C plus
for example Spotify a popular music
streaming application
its backend code is written in C plus
plus
we all know YouTube
C plus plus is used in building YouTube
video processing function
the Amazon application
that we use often
was also written in C plus plus
however there are changes over the years
and many more softwares like these are
developed using C plus plus
some of the main reasons for choosing C
plus plus for big projects is that it is
fast and efficient language also it
gives a lot of control when it comes to
memory management
and its Library support helps in making
complex functionalities
now let's move on to our next reason
which is
Community Support of C plus plus
as we have discussed C plus plus is an
old language and is being studied and
learned by most of the programmers
around the globe
so it has a huge Community Support
in case someone needs any help or
guidance regarding C plus plus a lot of
programmers and experts are out there on
different platforms creating resources
like blogs for example C plus plus tips
of the week
podcasts like CPP cast and the
organizations like the C plus plus
Alliance and many more are out there
that can guide you through your problem
all of these resources are open source
and some of them are paid which can help
a learner or programmer to understand
this language and clear the doubts
regarding it
now our next reason is C plus plus is
required everywhere
C plus plus programming language is
almost everywhere around the world
for example it is used for making
browsers applications and software
also C plus plus is used majorly to make
operating systems and almost all of the
plating systems are built with C plus
for example Mac operating system Windows
operating system Linux Etc
similarly the browsers like Safari Opera
Chrome Firefox Etc are written in C plus
because it is fast and efficient
language that is why it is more
preferable
many games are written in C plus plus
and some Advanced gaming systems are
also developed using C plus plus
language
so it is being widely used and learning
a language like this opens up the doors
for your career to many different
sectors of organizations
so next our fifth reason to learn C plus
plus is
it helps you in learning other
programming languages
C plus plus is an intermediate level
language
learning this language will give you
much deeper understanding of programming
structure because in C plus plus you
have to write declare and explain
everything in the source code
which gives you deeper knowledge of all
the parts of the program
languages like python are much easier to
understand because it is almost syntax
free language and you don't have to
specify everything while writing its
code
which makes the programming part easy
but you don't get the opportunity to
learn the logic structure of the program
like C plus plus
once you learned the C plus plus
language then other languages will be
easy for you to learn or grasp
as your foundation becomes strong
now our next reason to learn C plus plus
is embedded systems
an embedded system is a microprocessor
based software and Hardware system
that is used to design a specific
function
C plus plus is widely used in embedded
system because it is intermediary
language which means that it has both
the features of high level language and
low level language
which gives C plus plus an edge over
other languages because it directly can
access the hardware part without
sacrificing the high level part
many embedded systems like smart watches
GPS systems MP3 players Etc are created
using C plus plus
to choose a language for embedded system
C plus plus is the one
because it is Hardware level language
moving on to the next reason which is
versatility
C plus plus is around 40 years old
language and still is one of the most
popular language why is it so
it is because of its versatile nature
C plus plus is a highly adaptable
language and because of that it is still
useful when it comes to software and
developing games
it is widely used for so long that it is
compatible with many languages and is in
demand in many sectors
also the top tire companies seek
employees with a fine understanding of C
plus plus programming which is a very
good reason to learn C plus plus
programming
so next our top second reason which is
C plus plus language for simulations
apart from python C plus plus is also
used for simulations
many simulators are created with the
help of C plus plus libraries it is
considered as an alternative to the
Python language
the object-oriented approach provides
faster execution full accessibility to
the base language
portable models and executables
and a variety of complementary
development tools
the simulation built with tools has the
benefits of an object oriented design
including the involvement of
encapsulation polymorphism inheritance
and parameterized typing
now let's move on to the top reason to
learn C plus programming in 2022
that is
C plus plus has high salary packages
C plus plus is in demand in reputed
organizations like Facebook Google Etc
these organizations also pay some
handsome salary to the C plus plus
Developers for working on their products
usually different organizations pay
differently to the entry level C plus
developers and the experienced ones but
the average salary of a c plus developer
in India is 7 lakh 78 290.
and the average salary of a C plus plus
developer in USA is
118
305 dollars
the entry level C plus developer salary
is bit average in the early one to three
years because of less experience and
mastering C plus plus language usually
takes some time
but the salary package grows after four
years of experience at a fast pace which
is a good reason to learn C plus plus
programming language
how you can install C plus plus on vs
code and Dev C plus plus after we are
done with installation we'll also learn
how to run a program on both of these
code editors so we'll start with Visual
Studio code
to download vs code let's go to Google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official webpage for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
Windows Blue Button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading Visual Studio
code for Windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is a setup wizard
we'll click on this I accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the license
agreement now we can select our
destination folder or we can leave it as
it is but make sure there must be 293.2
MB of free space on that particular disk
space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on X there is no
need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as per your
choice
now we'll click on next
and now we'll click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch Visual Studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the C plus
plus programs can run in this code
editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code Runner
extension we'll write code Runner
and this is the extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on Control Plus alt plus n or press F1
and then select type run code but we'll
deal with it later
now
we'll add another extension that is C
slash C plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here we can see downloading Visual
Studio Windows debugger
it is getting installed and I think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of C
plus plus in this code editor
we can Define strings as a collection or
group of characters it is basically used
to represent text in the program and we
can perform many operations on strings
in order to manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes for example here string is
the type Str is the name of the string
and coffee is the value that is assigned
to the string
in C plus plus there are two ways to
create a string
first is C style strings in C style
strings collection of characters are
stored in the form of arrays they are
basically arrays of type character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
Library which we must include in the
program using hash include
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pull
back operation on it so first of all
we'll include the header file
hash include IO stream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay now we'll start
with int Main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type then the name of the string s
here s is the name of the string all
right now first of all we will display a
message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string so get line C in is used to
take the input and S is the name of the
string
so this is how we take the input
and now we will print another message
saying that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line handle okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
as Dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll write y
now
will display a message saying
after
using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function
pushback the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function s dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so we will write C out
and we'll display the message
after using PowerBack function
foreign
and we'll print the
string
okay now after that we'll write return
0.
and I think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string so let's say I have entered
Barcelona
so you have entered Barcelona after
using pushback Barcelona why because we
have used y over here we want to add y
at the end of the string so after using
pushback Barcelona Y and pop back
function after that we have used and we
know that it will delete the element
from the end so here we can see there is
no y pop back function have deleted the
element
so this is our output
next is if else statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example
if the number variable here is equal to
10 then only the block of code will
execute and will print the message you
got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file we'll go to
file and click on this new file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot CPP dot CPP is extension
which is used when we want to do a
program in C plus plus
now I will click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
which include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
now inside end main will display a
message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to
save this after making changes or you
can click on Ctrl s or you can go to
file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button it will
run the code
as we can see in the output
welcome to this video we can see
here it is
so it means our program is working it is
running fine now let's do another
example in which we will take the inputs
from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now we'll save as
and we'll write visual
2 dot CPP
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files hash include iostree
our spelling is wrong hash include
iostream after that using namespace
standard
now inside int Main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first number
Now using C in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this declare this
N1 variable so write int N1
int and 2.
and int
sum equals zero
all right here we have taken the input
of N1 the first number now we'll take
the input of another number by
displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write N2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
N2
and will display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
we'll go to file and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
I will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code and to do that
we'll go to file
and will now go to preference and in the
settings we'll click on the settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code Runner running
terminal in my via Studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to write in terminal or enter the
inputs in the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and then you can control s that
is save and then you can close the vs
studio and then open it again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
four
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
nine
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of C plus plus in Visual Studio
code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure Visual Studio code for C
plus plus programs so let's move on to
learn how we can download Dev C plus
plus and run C plus plus programs in
that
so let's go to Google
and type Dev C plus plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that now this is the
green button saying download will click
on that to download Dev C plus plus
as we can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 MB
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is Dev C plus plus setup now
we'll click on this setup
we click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is English we'll click on OK
now we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on I agree
now
we'll click on next we don't need to
change this I think the space required
is 346.8 MB
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can but I don't
want to change it so I'll click on
install
now it is getting installed it will take
a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked so when we click on
finish it will launch the dev C plus
plus
so here we have to select the language
it is English so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on OK
so this is our code editor that is Dev C
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and we
click on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev.cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include I have stream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
STD
because we want to check that whether
the program is running in this editor or
not
namespace STD
now we'll write int Main
inside int main will display a message
welcome
to
Dev C plus plus
all right after that we'll write return
0.
now let's try to run this and in order
to run this program we'll go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the pop-up welcome to Dev C
plus plus as we can see this is the
output now press any key to continue it
will close this window
so our output is correct welcome to Dev
C plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in Dev C plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
so this is how you can download both of
these code editors to run the C plus
programs today we'll be discussing about
loops in C plus plus so let's begin and
see what's in it for you
so we are going to be learning today
about why Loops what is a loop then
different types of Loops like for Loop
while loop do while loop then there is
nested Loop after that there are control
flow statements like break and continue
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting Tech
videos
so let's start with the first topic that
is while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops these are used when we want to
execute a block of State repeatedly
rather than just writing those
statements again and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times
now to do that there are threads which
is writing unit 50 times by doing the
hard code and Method 2 is writing your
name once with the loop condition and
your name will be automatically
displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach because you
don't have to put effort in writing your
name 50 times plus it is easy to write
code in few lines
so method 2 is the functionality of loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the simplicity
now let's understand what is a loop
Loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
Loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop after
the initialization the condition is
checked if it's true then the blog of
statement will get executed as long as
the condition is true and if the
condition is false the loop will
terminate
program different types of Loops are
used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for Loop then while loop then
there is do while loop after that there
is nested Loop these are four types of
Loops in C plus plus so let's discuss
these loops
first is for Loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the loop body is executed and once if it
transforms the execution of statement
will get terminated and after every
execution of for Loop the incremental
decrement parts will update the loop
counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this Loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute and this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false and
when it becomes false the loop will end
now the main difference is we use for
Loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while Loops when we don't
know the accurate number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next Loop that is do
by Loop
this Loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true after that it
will repeat the loop as long as the
condition is true
that means in do while blue body will
execute at least once irrespective of
the test condition
now coming to the nested Loop
when one Loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested Loop in C plus plus there are at
least 256 levels of nesting and the flow
of execution for nested Lopez First it
includes initialization of variable
followed by condition 1 if it gets
satisfied then it will search for the
second condition if that also gets
satisfied then it will get increment and
when the condition gets satisfied it
will search for the new set of
statements and follows the same flow of
execution
in C plus plus break statements are used
to terminate the execution of the loop
and by terminating the execution of loop
we means finishing or stopping the
execution like if we want to block or
terminate a loop at some point all we
need to do is to use the break statement
with a condition on which we want the
loop to stop and it will terminate the
Loop's flow or iterations so break
statements are mainly used for two cases
one is it can be used inside the loop
and second is it is mostly used in
switch statements and this is the loops
flow diagram in which first there is a
loop body then if the condition is true
then there is a break statement which
will terminate the loop and if the
condition is not true then the loop will
continue to iterate
as you can see in this example the loop
is iterating from 0 to 10 inside the
loop there is a condition and then the
break statement which will make sure
that the loop will terminate when I
becomes equal to 4. after the break
statement the control will jump out of
the loop body and that's how the break
statement Works its output would be 0 1
2 3. it will not exceed 4 because of the
break statement now coming to continue
statement the continue statement is a
bit similar to the break statement as it
is also used for termination but the
difference is that it is used to
terminate the current iteration and not
the complete Loop for example if a loop
is iterating from 0 to 6 and inside the
loop there is a continue statement on 4.
then all the elements will be printed
except for because continue statement
skips that particular iteration and
continues with the next one
and in break statement the complete Loop
flow terminates
so when the continue statement is used
then within the loop the control skips
or terminates that particular iteration
and continues with the next iteration
as you can see in this example first
Loop body
then there is a condition if that is
true then the continue statement will
terminate and continues it with the next
iteration and if that is false then
control will go to the remaining part of
the as always
now in this example we are using
continue statement here the loop is
iterating from 0 to 10
inside the loop there is a condition and
then the continue statement which will
make sure that if the value of I becomes
4 then terminate that iteration and
moves to the next iteration
after that elements are getting printed
with the help of C out function
now its output would be 1 2 3 5 6 7 8 9.
it will not display 4 because of
continuous statements as we know that
the continuous statement skip that
particular iteration so when we use I
equals 2 equals to 4 then it skips that
particular iteration
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
all right so as we have covered the
theoretical part so now let's do some
examples on break and continue
statements in our code editor that is vs
code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
loops.cpp
okay
oops1.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we have to print the digits from 0 to 10
using for loops it will be a basic
program just to understand it
write the header file
hash upload I'll stream
now I will write using namespace
standard
now here is the ink name
now we'll write the for loop with a 4
keyword
inside the for Loop
will initialize I with 0
now we'll put a condition I less than
equal to 10.
which means
the loop will keep on executing until I
is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment I plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print I
so that all the digits get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10. as we can see that I have made
i 0
to I less than equal to 10 that means
Loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return zero
after the loop it's a good practice
now I'll again run it
the output would be the same but it's a
good practice to write return 0 in the
end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so instead of writing the
hard code we can just use the for Loop
in this case
it's a basic example of for Loop but you
can try some more examples in order to
understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
to understand it better
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy New Year 11 times
let's start first of all let's name this
file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is Hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now is the main
now first of all we'll declare n equals
0 we'll take a variable n and initialize
it with 0.
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11.
now here all we have to do is to print
happy New Year so that it will get
printed along with the Loop 11 times
now we'll write n Plus 2.
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output happy New Year 11
times so this is how it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
foreign
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops3.cpp
I think the name is already taken
then we'll write loots4.cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write hash include I have stream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write incline
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
I
with 0.
now the syntax will do while loop is
do keyword
and now we will add some code inside the
body
will write sum equals sum plus I
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and I variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum that is why we have to
store it in a single variable
now we will need to increment I or else
Loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
I less than 10 we have written I less
than 10 because we want to find the sum
from 0 to 9.
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of 2 while loop
now we will print
some
in this while loop
we'll write sum is
some variable
now this Loop will keep on executing
till I is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number I is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller then the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
sum is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is
sum is 45.
which is the right answer this is our
output
so this is how it is done in do while
loop
so now let's do one example of our last
Loop that is nested Loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops pipe.cpp
now we'll start with the header files
Now using space standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form using nested Loop
so let's try
we'll write int Main
now let's initialize two variables that
is I
and J
now let's say we want to make a half
here made of 10 rows then it means we
need to run a loop which runs for 10
times
so let's write
or
initialize it to zero
I less than
10.
I plus plus
now here we have written I less than 10
instead of this we'll write I less than
equal to 10 because we want the 10th row
to be printed also
now we will print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we'll write another for Loop
which will decide number of stars in a
particular row
so we'll write J equal to 1 because this
for Loop is for the column section
then J less than equal to I
which is a row
then G plus plus
now we'll print star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write I equals to 1. because we want to
print stars from 1 to 10.
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have I equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening that is J equal to 1
validated by J less than equal to I
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of Star as the number
of rows increments
so for I equals to 1 J equals to 1 is
executed then J plus plus is done which
increments the value of J to 2.
now J equals to 2 failed to execute as 2
is less than equal to 1 is false
therefore only one star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith Loop now for I equal
to 2 we'll check every value of J which
can be executed that is 1 and 2. since
only two values can be true therefore 2
Star are printed
similarly we check for I equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9. as we have the
condition I is less than 10.
foreign
so now we'll try to run this
and check whether the pattern is
printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars with the
help of nested loops
so this is our star petrol
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
and let's name this file as
Ctrl 1.
CPP
now we'll write the header file and the
namespace standard as we have done
previously
so let's do it
Dash include
live stream
using namespace STD
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 hundred and twenty hundred and
thirty with a gap of 10. but after 150
we will terminate the ongoing Loop now
how can it be done with the help of
break statement so let's start
first of all we'll write intimate
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200 because we want the loop to run
from 100 to 200.
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
thank you now we'll write an if
condition that if num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll implement this
by 10.
we're incrementing this byte end because
we want the numbers to be printed like
100 100 and 10 120 like this that is why
we are incrementing it with 10 and not
with one
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return zero
now we'll try to run this
here we can see yeah here we can see 100
110 120 up 250 after that we are out of
the loop
this means
the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement now after this we'll do
another example of continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
ctrl2.cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90.
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into Main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition num greater than equal to 90
because we want the loop to run till it
is equal to 90. that is why we have
wrote greater than equal to 90.
basically we want the loop to run from
100 till it becomes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition in order to skip 96. so we'll
write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 and
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that write
value is
and we'll write the variable num
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay I think there are some errors
so
some brackets were missing
thank you
and we'll write return 0.
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as we can see
199.98 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all today we'll be discussing about
C plus functions so let's go ahead and
look what's in it for us
first we'll discuss what is a function
then we'll understand why we use
functions then types of functions like
built-in function and user defined
function then function declaration after
that function calling then function call
methods and at last we have recursion
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to the first topic that is
what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can Define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name then
inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again which reduces
the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in C
plus plus that is built-in functions and
user defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or Library functions we don't
need to Define these functions because
these are already present in C plus
libraries and the implementation of
these functions are also available in
library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them now coming to the user defined
functions
C plus plus allows us to Define our own
functions these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function Hair Club is a user defined
function with the return type void and
it is being called from the main
function
now let's learn about function
declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function functions name the
number of parameters in the function and
its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the Syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function int
is the return type chest is the name of
the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function when a program
calls a function the control of the
program is transferred to the called
function and when the code function
completes its task then the control is
returned back to the main program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax first we will
write the function name and after that
we will write the arguments which you
want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments so first is
call by value
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values here
well 1 and well 2 are the actual
parameters these are those which are
passed to the functions and inside the
brackets of call function we can see N1
and N2 these are formal parameters
foreign parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is well 1 and well 2
will be copied to the formal parameters
that is N1 and N2
now let's have a look at an example in
which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to X and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it
and inside the brackets we are passing
the values of X and Y
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of X and Y are then
displayed inside int Main
but its output is same
X is still 120 and Y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that change is done to the
parameters inside the function does not
affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped with the help of temp
variable and then it is getting
displayed in the main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped m is now 300 and N is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in a code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start first of all let's make a
new file and name it
call one dot CPP
now we will include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we will add namespace standard
foreign
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27
000 let's say
salary to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as salary
underscore change
and now inside the brackets we'll write
cell
as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside Main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and handle
now return zero
now let's make the function salary
change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
it's void
now here we will write hint the data
type
and the variable
s that is the formal parameter cell here
is the actual parameter and S is the
formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say 30 000.
here we have assigned as 30 000 earlier
the value of cell was 27 000 and then we
passed the copy of the variable cell
to the function salary change and there
we assign 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
inside function
[Music]
cell
handle
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
foreign
function is 30 000. and value inside
main is 27 000.
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes so we can say
changes are not reflected to the
original value which happens in call by
Value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
called to
dot CPP
let's include the header files
hash include
i o stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
foreign
here we will declare a variable cell
and assign 27 000 to it
as we have done previously
now we'll call a function named
increment
foreign
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just write the
message saying
salary
inside Main
and
we'll write the variable cell
then handle
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
so
and here
we'd write Ampersand sign s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value for the
variable here we are passing the address
of the variable
so that is why we have used Ampersand
sign now
we will simply write the logic to
increment
so we'll write s equals S Plus
5000 let's say we want the salary to
increment by 5000.
foreign
the variable s so first of all we'll
write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that and
then
now let's try doing this
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output thirty two
thousand and thirty two thousand so
these were some basic examples of call
by value and call by reference now here
we will do a program in which we have to
do the sum of two integers with the help
of function
so let's first of all make a new file
function dot CPP
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is Hash include as stream
now on the namespace standard
now we will write int Main
now inside end main we'll declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and 5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments now we'll
make the function sum
here end is the return type
sum is the name
and
a comma ENT B
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
C
now we will write C equals a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable C
now as we know that the return type is
end so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
C
now in the main function
we'll print that variable
we will print the variable as because
after the function completes its task of
addition the output will come back to
the calling function which is getting
stored in the variable s
so
we'll write
the result is
now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is 10.
five plus five on addition will get 10.
let's write three
and again
try to run this
the result is 8.
5 plus 3 equals to eight so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example of C plus
plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number or greater number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include IO stream
Now using namespace standard
now first of all we'll write the in
plane
now the variable N1
now we will declare another variable N2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
now we'll take the input
N1
now we'll do the same for the other one
we'll write
thank you
enter the second number
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say maxi
and we will pass these arguments N1
comma into
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables N1
oh yeah and two
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition
if N1 is greater than N2
then it must print the N1
we will also display a message saying
that
the larger number is
foreign
if N1 is greater than N2 then we'll
display the N1
and
if N2 is greater
then we'll display the N2
we'll write the variable N2
so let's see if that runs or not
I think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number so we will write
let's say
56
and the second number would be
78
the larger number is 78. so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic samples of C
plus plus functions and in today's
session we will learn about C plus plus
recursion now let's have a look at what
we'll be covering today
first of all we'll discuss what is
recursion then we'll understand the
working of recursion that is how it
actually works after that we will learn
about types of recursion and at last we
will go through the advantages and
disadvantages of recursion so what is
recursion recursion can be defined as a
process in which a function calls itself
again and again until a certain
condition is met recursion basically
brings about several number of iterative
calls to the same function
however it is important to have a base
case to end the recursion
for example imagine you are calling your
friend again and again for an urgent
piece of work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
your call is the termination condition
and this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now let's understand it's
working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case in the recursive case the
function is being called by itself again
and again and the base case is when the
function finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5 in this
problem we can see a pattern n into
factorial of n minus 1. to be clear n is
5. so n minus 1 is 4. and it is going on
till n becomes 0. so here factorial is
the recursive function and N minus 1 is
the argument that is getting passed for
every n into the recursive function in
this case if n becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and N into factorial
n minus 1 is the recursive condition
now let's understand the types of
recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly although there is no
base case in this example but it shows
the idea of direct recursion
now coming to indirect regression when a
function calls itself indirectly that is
if a function calls some other function
to make a recursive call then it is
known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion now coming to
advantages and disadvantages of
recursion the advantages are in
recursion we only need to define the
base case and the recursive case
so therefore it provides a Simple and
Clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals Tower of
annoy graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems now
disadvantages disadvantages are the
recursive program generally acquires
more space than the iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls now let's
do some examples of recursion on our
code editor that is vs code now here we
will do a program in which we will find
the sum of natural number up to a number
which we will enter and we will do this
example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we'll name this
recursion
dot CPP
okay now we will start with writing
header file that is Hash include
iostream
now we'll add namespace standard
using name space
STD
now first of all we'll write intman
now we will declare a variable let's say
num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
celebrate
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like C out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
to that let's write return 0.
now let's make this function some
will write int the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
foreign
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as
we'll make if
num
is not equal to zero
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num Plus
some
num minus 1.
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function some function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
Okay so
now after this
will
try to run this
enter the number let's say
five
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15.
okay let's recheck 5 plus 4 equals to 9
9 plus 3 equals to 12 12 plus 2 equals 2
14 14 plus 1 equals to Fifteen so our
answer is correct
so this is how we can find the sum up to
any numbers which we want to find the
sum of and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot CBP
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream that is the header file
Now using namespace standard
now we'll write int Main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll
display a message saying enter the
number
now we will take the input
we'll write number
now we will call a function and we will
send the pass the argument number as we
have done in the previous question
so let's do it
first of all we'll display that
saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
will pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write return 0.
now let's make this function
we will write the in return type int
now fact
after that now we will write the
argument
number
now we will write if condition
and we'll write
number
less than one
and we will return
one
so here we have wrote this condition
because as we know that the factorial of
0 is 1 and if a number is less than 1
that it means it is 0 and if it is 0
then our program should return 1.
and
you will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive condition
that is
number
into
fact
number minus 1.
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number
for example if we input 5 then here we
can see the condition would become 5
into fact 5 minus 1 that is 4. and this
4 will be passed as argument to this
fact function and then the condition
would become 4 into fact 4 minus 1 that
is 3 and it is also passed to the
function and similarly it will go on
until it becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is uh this is
the base case and this is the recursive
case in this program
now after that let's do one last example
of recursion
okay so now let's make new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
I have stream
now namespace standard using name
space standard
so here we will do the program of
Fibonacci series and we know that
Fibonacci series is basically each num
in Fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start so first of all we'll
make int Main
now we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so first of all we'll display a
message saying that
enter the number
now we'll take the input
we'll write num
now
we will make a for Loop and iterate that
loop from i 0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int I equal to 0
I less than num
I plus plus
now inside the loop we will write C out
to display and we will call fibo
function and we will pass I as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so we will write C out
fibo
and we'll pass I
as an argument and
just for the space
now I will write return
0.
in fibo function we have passed is an
argument because we want to print the
series so first 0 will be passed then 1
will be passed after then 2 will be
passed and so on
so now we will make the function fibo
and is the return type fibo is the name
now the argument num
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1. if yes we will return
the value of num else we will
recursively call fibo using n minus 1
and N minus 2 because Fibonacci series
is basically the sum of previous two
numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num is less than equal to 1.
then
return
num
num
else
return
fibo
num minus 1
Plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2.
because we know
Fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1 then it will go to the if
statement and if it is greater than a 0
and 1 then it will go to this recursive
statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 this will be valuated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number let's say six
all right
zero one one two three five which is the
right answer
the Fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do Fibonacci
series or Fibonacci Sequence with the
help of recursion
and I suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better in this session we will learn
about fan functions in C plus plus so
let's go ahead and have a look at what
will be covering today in this session
we will cover topics like why do we need
a friend function what is a friend
function in C plus plus then the
Declaration of friend function and after
that we will learn what is a friend
class then we will understand features
of friend function and its advantages
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so
first is why do we need a friend
function friend functions are used when
we want to access the private or
protected members of the class but
without the help of the objects it helps
us in avoiding the case where the
functions must be a member of both the
classes in order to access them or in
other words a function doesn't have to
be a member of both the classes in order
to access the class data a friend
function is also used to perform
operator overloading like functions
operators can also be overloaded and
because of the friend function it is
possible now let's understand what is a
friend function a friend function is not
a member function of the class and it is
defined outside the class
and we know outside members cannot
access the class data but the friend
function can access those private public
and protected class data because the
friend function is friendly with the
class now let's move to Declaration of
friend function the Declaration of Rand
function must be done inside the class
the friend function is declared using
the front keyword then the return type
then the name of the function that is
made a friend of the class its
definition is done outside the class and
we don't use the front keyword while
defining it but while declaring it
inside the class we use the front
keyword now coming to the next topic
that is what is a friend class exactly
like a friend function a class can also
be a friend of another class A Friend
class is that class that can access the
data members and member functions of a
class to which it is a friend we need to
pass the objects of the class us to a
member function of the friend class if
we want to access those private and
protected members also if the classes
are declared friends then all the member
functions of the class will be a friend
function to the friend class now let's
have a look at the syntax here we have
done the forward Declaration of class
table this will allow the access of the
objects of the class table in the class
club inside the class club we have
declared friend class table that means
the class table is a friend of class
club and it can access members of that
class after that we have defined the
class table without the front keyword as
we can see now coming to features of
friend function so here are some
features of friend functions so let's
start with the first one that is a
friend function can be easily involved
just like a normal function it doesn't
require any object or so to invoke
next is the scope of a friend function
is not limited it can be a member of
another class as well third is a friend
function can be declared in any part
that is private protected or public
parts of the class fourth is the object
of the class can be used as an argument
for the function and the last is a
friend function can access the members
by using the object name and Dot
operator along with the member's name
now coming to advantages of friend
function the First Advantage is with the
help of Rand function we are able to
access the non-public members of the
class that is the private members the
second Advantage is fan function helps
in operator overloading and the third
Advantage is because of the friend
function we are able to share the
private information by a known member
function as friend function is not a
member function the last Advantage is
fan function allows us to generate more
more efficient code so these were some
advantages of friend function so now
let's go ahead and do some examples on
friend functions to understand it in a
better way so let's open our Visual
Studio code and do some examples so
first of all let's make a new file let's
name it friend1 dot CPP
all right so now here we'll do a simple
program of friend function so let's
start with including the header file
Dash include our stream
now we will write using namespace
standard
all right
and inside the main function first of
all we will create an object of a class
let's say the name of the class is
salary and the name of the object is s
all right after that we will
simply write return 0 and we will do the
rest of this after creating the class so
we need to First create the class now
we'll write class
salary which is the name of the class
and inside this class first of all we'll
write private access modifier and here
we will write or declare a variable
named cell after that now we will write
or declare the friend function so we
know how to declare a friend function
we'll write friend keyword
then the return type that is int and
then the name of the function let's say
increment and then the objects as we
know we have to pass
the name of the class with the object
because we want to access the private
member of the class
so salary s which is the object
and after the class we'll write the
semicolon now we have to create or
Define this increment friend function
we'll write
int increment here we haven't used the
front keyword because this is the
definition now inside the arguments
we'll pass the
the object
all right now inside the main function
we will call this friend function so
first of all we will display a message
saying that
increment
is
that the increment in the salary is
and then we will call this function
and we will pass this object
all right now inside this increment
function which is a friend function we
will use object as dot operator and then
the name of the variable which is
private
now all we need to do is to increment
this salary variable so we'll write s
dot cell plus 7000 which is the
increment and then we will return
s dot cell all right now as we can see
this increment function which is not a
member function of this class is
accessing this private variable of
salary class and is incrementing 7000 to
the salary so now let's save it first
and let's try to run this
there is some error let's have a look at
that
all right yeah there's some spelling
mistake increment now let's save it
and run it so as we can see increment is
7000 so this is the correct output
so this was a simple example of friend
function let's do another example so
here we will do an example of friend
class and we know friend class is a
class that can access the data members
and member functions of a class to which
it is a friend
so let's start first of all we'll
include the header files
hash include iostream
and then the namespace standard
and we forgot to name this file so let's
do it let's name it friend2.cpb
all right now let's proceed
didn't mean inside the main function
first of all we will create an object of
a class let's say the class name is num2
and its object is obj2 object two now
for now let's say we'll write only
return 0 we'll do this part later
onwards now let's create the class all
right so the class name would be num2
num1 actually but we know in front class
we have to do the forward declaration so
we will write class num 2 so this is a
forward Declaration of class num2 now
inside class num1 first of all we'll
declare a variable in private
so let's say the name of the variable is
int N1 enters the data type and one is
the name of the variable now we have to
do the Declaration of friend class so
we'll write front keyword after that
class
num2 which is the name of the class
all right after this let's create this
first of all we have to put the
semicolon all right now let's write this
class num2
so this is our friend class num2 we
haven't used front keyword over here as
we can see
all right in this class we'll use a
private access specifier and
we'll create another variable N2 and
then we will write the public access
specifier and we will create a
Constructor of num2 as this is the name
of the class and this is object we have
created so now we will create the
Constructor of this class
num2
and now in this Constructor we will
initialize N2 which 65 or whatsoever
number we want because in the end we
have to find the average of two
variables so this is the second variable
N2 and we have assigned the value 65 so
now let's make the function of average
because we want to find the average of
both the numbers
so enter the data type AVG is the name
of the function let's say and inside
this function we will make an object of
num1 class and the object name is obj1
now as we have created the object
by mistake we have wrote I obj1 so as we
have created the object of num1 class
which its Constructor would be invoke
which we will create now but first of
all here we will write return
the average so we'll write obj1 Dot N1
plus and 2.
divided by
2.
so as we know that obj1 is the object of
num1 class so that is why we have used
obj1 dot operator N1 that is the name of
the variable plus N2 divided by 2 from
here we can find the average and before
that we have to create the Constructor
of this class
so now all we need to do is write Public
Access modifier
now num1 and inside this num1 we will
assign the value to N1 variable which is
let's say 11. all right so now in the
main function we have to call this
function avj that is the average
function and we forgot to put semicolon
over here all right now
will display a message average is
and now we will call the function obj2
dot AVG which is a function so here we
are calling this function so let's save
this so we have saved this now let's try
to run this one as you can see the
average is 38 so
65 plus 11 6 and 76 divided by 2 which
is 38 so this is the correct output so
this is a fine example of friend class
as we know class num2 is a friend of
class num1 so it can access all the
members of class num1 in class num2 we
have created the function AVG over here
this is the function AVG here we are
doing the average of both the numbers
and as class num2 is a friend of num1 so
we can create objects of num1 in num2
class
and after doing this this is our output
that is average is 38 so this is an
example of friend class now let's do
another example so here we will do an
example of Rand function in which a
friend function is a friend to two
classes and this would be an example in
which we have to do the product of two
numbers so let's start first of all
let's include the header files as we
have done previously
IO stream
namespace standard
now let's save it
friend3.cpp and
spelling is wrong
now let's start with the main function
inside the int main first of all we will
create the object of Class A that is a
and Class B object would be small B
and we will use these objects to call
the functions but we will do that part
later onwards first of all we'll simply
write return 0 over here and now we will
create the classes all right so here we
will create a class but before that we
have to do the forward Declaration of
another class so this is the forward
Declaration of Class B and now we can
create the class A and inside the a
class we will declare the variable X
let's say now we will use this public
scope
and we will create a function within
this class let's say void assign
now inside this function we will pass
the variable I because because we have
to assign the value of this variable I
to the variable X
so
we will assign the value of I to X
like this and before that we have to do
the calling from the main function so we
will do that later first of all we will
create the front function and here we
are declaring this print function
void is the return type product let's
say is the name of this friend function
and a comma B are the arguments
now let's call this assign function
first of all so all we need to do is we
will make a call from this main function
a DOT assign which is the name of the
function and let's say we have passed
the value 45 now here we will create the
class B
inside the b class we'll similarly
create another variable y
and now inside the public scope we will
create function of the same name that is
assign now in this assign function we
will pass
I as the argument as we have done in
class A similarly we'll do it over here
we will assign the value of I to this
variable y
once we have done this
then we will declare friend function as
we know that the front function is
friend of both of these classes so we
have to do it inside both of these
classes we have to declare the friend
function and now we will declare the
front function in this class as well
product
all right after the class we will use
the semicolon now
we will create the friend function so
here we are defining the front function
we use void product which is the name of
the function now data type object name
all right now all we need to do is we'll
do this sum a DOT X into B dot Y and now
we'll use semicolon so here a DOT X will
hold the value which have been assigned
that is 45 and now B dot x b dot y will
hold the value which we will call from
here B dot assign
okay we are calling and we are assigning
the value let's say 20 you're passing
the value 20 and this 20 value
will be assigned to this Y and 45 into
20 would be the product
so everything is done now all we need to
do is to call the
product function and as we know that the
product function that is the friend
function is the friend of both of the
classes so it can access the private
variables so we'll do that
product
a comma B here we are calling this now
let's save this one and let's try to run
this
there are some errors let's check them
Class A all right so before go to make
some space over here now let's save it
again and let's try to run this
as we can see the output is 900 so 45
into 20 is equal to 900 which is the
correct answer
and it means the program is working fine
so this is a fine example in which a
function that is this product function
is a friend of both the classes that is
Class B and this class A here we have
done the forward declaration and we have
made the front of Class A and here we
have declared the friend function in
class B and as we can see that this
product function can use or access the
private variables of both the classes
and so this is by using the private
variables we we have done the product of
both of these numbers and its answer is
900 so these were some few examples of
rent functions you can try some more
examples on it it will enhance your
knowledge in Z Plus as it is an
interesting topic welcome to this video
on C plus plus header files and in
today's session we will learn about why
we need header files then what is c plus
header file after that we will learn
about types of header files and how can
we create our own header file and at
last we will have a look at some
examples of header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to gather the Declarations in one place
and then use them whenever we need them
and as all the Declarations are gathered
in one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
Declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files there are two types of
files in C plus first is predefined
header file these files are already
present in C plus compiler we simply
need to import these header files using
hash include which will inform the
compiler about the header file and then
we can write the name of the header file
between the angle brackets
next is user defined header file these
header files are defined or created by
users in C plus plus user can create
their own header file and include it in
the C plus library and it can be used
whenever it is required now let's learn
how to create this header file in order
to create your own header file first of
all we will write the C plus code which
we want to use whenever we want after
that we will save the file with dot h
extension as we can see in Step 1 we
have written the code of two integers
that are getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot h
extension
here hash include will inform the
compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in Step 2 after
the Declaration of two integers we are
calling the function product and passing
the arguments X and Y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45. because 9 into 5
equals 45 and we don't need to worry
about writing the logic of it because we
have already included this header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of C plus
plus IO stream became standard header
whose function is now in STD namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next is f stream fstream are associated
with files it is basically used to read
the information from files and write the
information in it
and next is IU manip IO manip is a
library that is used in the manipulation
of input and output statements
so these were some examples of header
files today we'll be discussing about C
plus plus array so without further Ado
let's get started so what's in it for
you
we will start by understanding why do we
need arrays then what is an array after
that types of array like one dimension
array two Dimension array
multi-dimension array and then memory
representation and lastly we'll go
through error initialization
so first is need of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contiguous block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contiguous memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array now
this is the way you can visualize the an
array here each block is capable of
storing data values of some type in
sequential Manner and each element can
uniquely identify by its index in the
array
and this is the syntax of array hint is
the data type array is the area name and
5 is the size of array
now there are few types of variance C
plus plus
those are
one dimension array two dimensional
array and multi-dimensional array so
let's first of all discuss 1D array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1D array type
is the data type then there is array
name and after that size of array and
this is the example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here array of 0 means 2 and array of 1
means 7 and so on
as each element is of type int that is 2
byte that means the array occupies 12
contiguous bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total 6
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional array
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices the first index shows a row of
the Matrix and the second index shows
the column of The Matrix now moving to
its memory representation
as you can see this is a 2d array with
three rows and three columns and we can
also say that these are basically three
1D array containing three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of 3 cross 3. the
horizontal line step its rows and the
vertical line step its columns and we
know that index starts from 0 so first
elements get stored at array 0 0 that is
0 through and zero column then second
element is stored at array 0 1 that is
zeroth row and column 1 and likewise all
the elements are stored in the array now
coming to the multi-dimensional array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimension
array is an array itself they can have
any number of dimensions and it stores
the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also a
multi-dimensional array
and this is the Syntax for a
multi-dimensional array
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes
after that this is the basic example of
a multi-dimensional array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in C plus first is you can
initialize an array when you declare it
by including the initial values in
braces after the Declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index 5 is at one
index one is at 2 index and so on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces
other than this we can set the value
after the Declaration by assigning the
element to the array using its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
array of 1 equal to 7 here we are
assigning 7 to index 1 and same goes for
the array of 2. now let's do some
examples on array to understand them
better we'll do these examples on our
code editor that is vs code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cppu
array1.cb
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
Dash include irstream
foreign
Spades standard
[Music]
I will write into Main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int
now we'll write the array name that is
let's say coupon
and now the size of array
let's say 6. foreign
braces
we'll write those elements
let's say five
eight
seven
three
nine
one
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here int means the data type coupon is
the array Name six is the size of array
and
587391 are the elements of array
now after that we'll write the for loop
with four keyword
now we'll initialize I with 0
I less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment I
now in this Loop all we have to do is to
print this array so how do we do that
so let's do c out
foreign
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put I inside the
array bracket now the loop will run from
i 0 to 6 and likewise all the elements
from 5 to 1 will get printed so let's
see
let's try to run this code
so this is our output
587391 so this is how we can print the
elements of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket let's say if
we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see 777 it is because of the loop that
from i 0 to I6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
foreign
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
let's name this file
array2.cbd
foreign
now in this example all we have to do is
to do the sum of all the elements of the
array
so let's start by writing our header
file
spec
[Music]
Now using namespace STD
now we'll write in command
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with 0.
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and N will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for Loop
and we will initialize with I equals 0.
I less than n which is the size of array
and will increment I plus plus
we are writing for Loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need four loops
so now we will scan the array
we'll write C in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write I
now here we have written I inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from I equal to 0 to n which
is the size of area
no
we'll take another for Loop
now here we will write another for Loop
in which we are initializing I from 0 to
n and inside that for Loop we will do
the sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
I less than n which is the size
now we will increment I plus plus
now inside this for Loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we will write sum as we know that we
have already initialized